what are Icelandic people like you got
to tell me you know I mean I don't know
how much I know about the people they
what I observed is they love wool they
love wool mm-hmm yeah they love wall
fish fish you love fish they get you
know very excited when it's not dark
anymore
right cuz it's dark wait a bit yeah and
then the Sun finally comes up oh and
they just go bananas they got very
excited about that right uh they really
seem to enjoy that they talk a lot about
like all the things that they do it and
I think there's a lot of depression yes
the kicks in I would love it I am with
you you know so much so that you know we
really started to think about you know
getting a summer home there and how
great it would be to just you know live
do it nicely are you being honest do you
really think about possibly not just
possibly like real estate brokers and I
mean you talk to real estate brokers
about getting a summer place why a
summer place in what's so appealing
about a certain place in Iceland um
well first of all what's not you know I
mean just the houses are great looking
and the people like I said are very
interesting um and I think it's just
really that the heat is disgusting you
know what you mean we're in in the rest
of the world
yeah just in general like in the world
you don't like heat I don't like hey I
don't like shorts I don't like the filth
and the muck that comes with it you know
I'm because I live in New York
yeah oh you don't like when in New York
and the summer it gets very hot and you
don't like people wearing shorts I I
think it's disgusting I mean I
understand the necessity but it makes me
very uncomfortable you don't like what
you're saying is you don't like bare
limbs well I do like having my limbs
exposed it makes me very tense right I
like to be I mean this is like a
contained environment you know yeah I've
been checked for life
I like if your you live in New York I
feel like it's some sort of
unintentional street smarts that you
know you just to come up with like as I
grow up in the city so when I see
somebody let's say in there like a man
and they're in flip-flops and they're on
the subway nothing makes me sicker you
know really yeah you hate just looking
at that guy's foot yeah I mean it's
disgusting are they in general it's like
a full-blown turnoff yeah you know a
straight man and a flip-flop I don't
care what you as far as I'm concerned
there's no excuse there's no patient for
it right so what you're basically saying
is you would buy a summer home in
Iceland because you know that it's so
cold
yes they didn't know it's gonna be a go
to that length not to see a man's
barefoot in a flip-flop that is exactly
what I'm saying that's swell you really
despise it you justify this bare flesh
yes right
[Applause]
guys wouldn't do that right what what no
I don't know I completely agree yeah I
mean it's now full nude like in the
movie
that's terrific film that's fine right
now right but if you notice it would
know flip-flops were there true that
there weren't flip-flop
yeah because kidding we wouldn't know
that's why it's a great film yeah an
excellent film so had that great film
had one scene where there were
flip-flops I couldn't I couldn't dilemma
Kate I couldn't I would have had to leak
we cut it out for the version to talk
I mean Taylor's in it love Taylor I you
know she's like a funny live Oldman in
it I would have had to leave yeah I
would have to leave well you always said
this it sounds like a phobia it's
actually in phobia not it's it's more
just uh you know all that hot flesh in I
it's just don't like I don't think I
just don't like it coupled with the dirt
and you know the element of like
strangers I think it's got a lot to do
it sort of like it occurs to me sitting
here with you that it's um taxi driver
risk you know what I mean it's a little
bit Travis Bickel the way I feel about
like the filth and the city streets and
like what a drag our brain is gonna come
and it's gonna wash these streets clean
right that's a little bit how I feel
about it I just thought that you said
sitting here with you I'm reminded of
Travis Beppo one of the great whenever
the snow comes coning that yeah you're
happy yeah this is nice first of all
everybody's covered up like respectable
people right you know and that would
just gum bags running around like
they're just sweating you guys Shum
bagging no shorts when they're fanny
packs and within Metro cards and the
flip-flops at obviating I can't handle
them yeah
all right sunblock that's where I draw
the line do not go after sunblock any
reason I'm still alive is because
there's an SPF I would be dead without
sunblock you should probably you know
get a house with us a nice